this is unexpected good morning guys
I feel awful today I got back from
playlist live a late last night and then
last night and this morning my body
decided that health is no longer one of
our special skills so I'm doing the
closest thing to take a day off from
making web videos by making a web video
explaining why this isn't a better web
video if this video goes viral I'm gonna
be so [ __ ] pissed so I apologize that
I'm not praising you guys today
you know you get those days where you
just have you have to lay in the bed
nobody just want take no for an answer
so I'm gonna listen tell me back
tomorrow with regularly scheduled
programming I just need you know a few
hours to just chill the [ __ ] out
I some [ __ ] up dreams last night oh and
then I dreamt about tweeting about the
dreams because I thought it would be a
good tweet yeah I need to take a break
take this day as a day off for
yourselves to do something good wash
your body I don't know why you're still
tickets to the Dublin nofilter show
please purchase them I'll be healthy for
that oh I'm gonna buy it green juice oh
I live in Los Angles first do a good
amount of time now but anyone get that
green juice doh